I mean that was the difference
definitionally between agnostics and
atheists right right so if you want to
say that if we go to have an agnosticism
and say maybe God exists maybe doesn't
but I don't have evidence of it so I
don't believe you know that's that's
borderline agnostic atheist that's fine
I mean it doesn't really matter I mean
to my central argument whether you're an
agnostic or an atheist the bottom line
is that without the belief that there is
a purpose to the universe without a
belief that there is a purpose to your
life without a belief that you have the
capacity to make individual choices it's
very difficult to build the civilization
by difficult I mean impossible okay I
think freewill by the way is the single
most important principle under girding
any civilization
yeah your own life you're not because
you chose to come here and you chose to
ask me a question right I would hate to
think that the universe randomly imbued
you with a set of atoms that showed up
here randomly to ask me a question
that'd be very disappointing to me